foreign
uh
May the force be with you I see you
I see you
I don't know
you know I don't know exactly where I
should uh
put this here
give me a second
Sharon on Twitter guys
all right there we go
let's do this
the next generation of Jedi
I love the sound
we seek a dangerous Fugitive
this is no common anarchist
but a devotee of the treasonous Jedi
Order no
no this is a lightsaber
I was alone for a long time I was scared
that they find out who I was or what I
was and you're not alone I love to have
him on IOP hey bd1 I'm Kel get your
lasers off my lunch I guess it's about
time I find out who I am huffle bubs
ain't gonna kill you kid Baron right
I've spent years waiting for a chance to
avenge my sisters I know what it's like
to lose everything night sisters I love
that game that do this survivors like a
lot of more developers need to
understand that in your head I ain't
played Fallen order in years imma forget
this is funny the majority
execute for the 66
every Jedi faces the dark side
but something different it's something
better she'll sell you out too you can't
stop the Empire I'm stronger now because
of the pain
such hatred
failure is not the end
Siri part of the path
hope will always survive in those who
continue to fight
I will never forget I will honor your
teaching and your sacrifice
by the right of the council calcas
rise Jedi Knight
remember trust only in the force
[Music]
[Applause]
so where to now
because for some reason it's not putting
my camera in this
all right there we go
let's just put it like that
you guys are gonna have to deal with it
webcam stuff there we go
just put it like that
there we go
I feel like that's good
started a new world order
all right
let's just do a balancing I don't want
to do anything that's going to upset me
just do balance
what I got to do anything extra
balances the way this is the white
[Music]
isn't that the Jedi Temple
oh they got you already
that was fast
[Music]
got me all ready
I'm already in handcuffs game ain't even
started
[Music]
just jump
you'll survive
do some Jedi trick right before you fall
man
look how good this game looks this game
looks very impressive
all right
see people really like cow cow is a
successful Star Wars character
he needs his own TV show
this dude got captured intentionally
[Music]
oh
I love the uh the sounds man
I do hear there's some issues with like
the performance I am in performance mode
so I'm wondering if that will prevent a
lot of the issues
foreign
play as much as I can today
[Music]
your business
oh
I believe the rumors
and this is this is when Vader is up and
at it man you know I'm not gonna spoil
anything from the first one
yeah but I'm very interested to see what
happens
[Music]
I think you got captured intentionally
oh
this way we're taking a detour
first game was amazing
I really enjoyed it
amazed
as long as I get paid
I don't like these on-rail moments
though they get on my nerves a little
bit
we're citizens
beat him
these days
good things
we've got something
this is crazy
what is that
attention level 2046
and children in place until further
notice security patrols will detain and
incarcerate anyone who does not comply
oh God
deals change not this one I come along
we walk only you the others must wait
it's crazy you're gonna let him call you
then
how'd you make the arrest
for the senator gets a hold of you he'll
wish you were dead it's always nice to
meet a fan
I like the action cow man
he was this way
yes I'm on the series X
she's very confident of himself this
time I don't think he would like that in
the original one but he seems very
confident in himself this time
a little bit of tearing right
now
is the district secure yes Senator it
better be
haters dogs are always sniffing about
Jedi is a rare Quarry these days
what else have you brought me
thank you
[Music]
his savior
yep
I wonder if he's got one so far so good
but I haven't really played a lot I just
started the game
the Renegade Jedi Cal castis
you have made quite a name for yourself
sabotaging weapons depots disrupting
supply lines flaunching this for
everyone to see
failed coup
or Norse it
that was your doing wasn't it
your cow is legendary now
a confession
you already know I've been working with
SAR Guerrera
before I deliver you to the emperor you
will lead me
to the remaining Jedi
[Laughter]
our use resisting
I'll find out one way or another
sometimes all it takes is a speech but
in there I have other tools at my
disposal or maybe I'll just use this
a traitor like you
and to think one day our children will
ask what is the
thing
this relic of a corrupt institution
wowed by its own arrogance
arrogance is a trap a lot of us fall
into senator
I'm sure the emperor won't mind if I
deliver you to him in pieces
probably
for sometimes I think you would want he
wants him alive yeah
he got captured on purpose you really
think you could Capture Me
I've got classified military Intel store
near yacht
it's brought it right to me it's
thanks PD
you take that lightsaber that's fine
yo
come and get me
one more more than what did you need to
fall
come on out more than one need to come
down oh my
okay okay
come on come on oh
there you go
no Force
it's okay
oh my God
I feel sexy I'm playing on performance
mode though
DMV grenade now he comes to us
uh he's coming a little high
oh really hot
so the set pieces we were having for the
first one
it's okay
oh these things happen
we gotta get to that yacht
all right so it's some climbing almost a
close one buddy
it's not your fault
catch up with the odd
oh we centered it
where you think the senator is I can't
believe they really thought they caught
a Jedi that easy
[Music]
about
so we're gonna try to shoot me
we gotta find that yacht before the
Empire does
I mean it's right there there's no
finding here it's literally right there
no it's not
get in there
[Music]
never until the Senators got stashed
hope it's worth a risk what's up dark
Raven never give up hope we know what I
know where that is it's a that's an old
republic thing old Raven
dark Raven
sorry just messaging someone on Discord
foreign
oh
yeah I am feeling like
some issues with the frame rate
occasionally
oh they brought the meditation thing
back
all right
let's do fours first
we have to get this one
I like that it kind of reminds me of
like the
Elder Scrolls Skyrim with like the the
the the Stars
let's move
what's up boys
come on yeah
your turn come on
I ain't scared
I need to record this too
for my review
oh yeah you definitely wasn't
Force push Force pull
got all the powers up in this man I love
Force powers
hologram unlocked
all right
yeah I remember this
that's the spirit Beady I'll get it
[Music]
sure sure
oh gotcha
thank you
which way do I go
I go back down more
it looks like a jump off here
okay
oh no is this it yeah I see him okay
guys it's a little god of war going on
right there
oh switch stances oh dual saver
nah we we fight we fight
come on guys
should do a little bit more than that
I feel like they should have maybe
unlock that
I feel like I won't enjoy it as much
because I feel like I unlocked it
crashes
I will ACG
um I I have noticed some
uh performance issues oh okay
[Music]
all right
can I just kill this dude here
[Music]
no I can't okay
ah getting closer go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go
don't look down
oh ah
just wait till I get to you
someone's Gonna Save Me
that's one of his people
yeah
who is that what took you so long
oh you know just hanging out taking in
the sights it's been a while since I was
on Coruscant
oh
[Music]
explode part of the job guess this
I think what I like the most about Jedi
Survivor and Jedi fall in order is it's
a confident story that doesn't spit in
the lore of the story if that makes
sense to you guys heading to the yacht
we'll meet him there oh and Bravo said
no cause no coms it is Bravo Knows Best
sometime
looks like that factory stop the yard
I call that a win oh okay okay left and
right is different stances okay let's
not keep them waiting
yeah I'm playing on the Xbox I think
that's one of the reasons it took me
along to get the review code is because
I'm on the Xbox and not uh I didn't ask
for another platform
I told him I'd take anything but I said
Xbox first I think they took that
literal
okay what you doing man
a little help Beauty are we gonna jump
that was close
I got no problem jumping
the problem is with you jump anything
yeah that's what I told them that I
would take anything but um I said Xbox
first so I think they took that literals
I don't know I'm just happy I got it
regardless
I was gonna play regardless but it's
nice to you know I was I was really
anticipating playing it
I just hate that there's so many
technical issues
sure
oh is this a Mandalorian stuff going on
oh did you just shoot that
you probably just killed a bunch of
people my dude
dude literally went over there
it just
knocked that giant crate down
kill him and take that like that my
master every time I fell he got me back
on my feet that was a good teacher to me
Stormtrooper Patrol
for us better us than the yacht
are we not scared of that
oh they won't let me go to them
so far so good
oh what is this
I assume I run and then jump
impressive who needs a jet pack we we
need a jet pack shut up see that cable
on it has this
[Music]
could totally use a jet pack
foreign
oh I'm always ready I'm always ready for
the smoke
kill who
with what
oh that's you I remember you
yeah I remember you
guys
nicely done back at you
can call the lift with that terminal on
it
oh okay
I call it I thought I had the robot do
it trooper's coming let's get the drop
on it that's your thing on your signal
[Music]
right bumper all right okay
all right ready to fire
okay I like this dude you can fight yeah
you too of course I can fight I don't
speak binary but I hear you BD team
effort
the yacht's just over there and of
course the bridge is under construction
let's try it that way quit reading my
mind Jedi
gotta be another route
oh man
oh
man who leads who needs Jedi when he's
got a suit
hold up let me meditate
[Music]
yeah oh I have to rest up
it should rest up by itself I shouldn't
have to like click the rest up one
it's okay though
didn't we come this way
of course changed a lot of those few
years these days just being outside's
asking for trouble
speaking of trouble let's avoid that
Patrol agreed
I think we could take him it's gonna be
real if you guys
I'll get you it's up to them
I hate probe droids same what's going on
guys
perfectly
that'll teach him
oh okay
I love how everyone is looking for this
dude
I think it's a coordinated attack what
are you doing here
oh we don't need you
oh
execute who
um
don't get used to the this timing
I love how a respawn feature they're
literally called respawn respawn
entertainment
do I have to fight some company and it
isn't friendly
foreign
let's try this again
come here buddy
team attacks
enemy's close I got your back Cal
M I love how that's where we're going
[Music]
let's get rid of these things
come on
yeah yeah yeah come on guys
[Music]
I like how you use your face block their
attacks yeah it takes me a little bit to
get used to it timings when I play these
type of games
double back
I wish there was more like
like decapitation and stuff when you hit
these because you should be going
through them I I get that's probably
like a Disney thing they don't want that
much violence in this game
thank you
all right so
the emperor turned the Jedi Temple into
his Palace yeah that's what the Empire
does best take something you love and
make it something you can't stand the
sight of anymore
foreign
oh that's disrespectful man
the Jedi Temple made it into his Palace
how long you've been working with saw
Guerrera
a few jobs here and there I can tell you
impressed him that isn't easy I'm good
at what I do
oh I like that oh
I assume he's a Mandalorian like one of
the newer mandalorians
the ones that have the mask off that
crane to get across the bridge let's
face McDonald's yeah
it's not a prank
I'm here
at least this dude's useful
jumping straight down
buddy I really needed that
was meditate we ain't using anything
right now though
we're just gonna rest I kind of want to
get used to
the game before I use any of his skill
points
I really wish I had that jet pack
that jet pack would be very useful right
now come here dude
yeah go out there
oh you want some too there you go
you want to join your friends oh
[Music]
you don't need to do anything
enemies down
look we're backtracking
I don't know
[Music]
something over here
I don't think we go this way
I guess let's just go the same way we
went
maybe we got to go back up and actually
make it this time
foreign
[Music]
I mean I can't but I don't think you
guys can do too much to me
they're on to us
[Music]
oh my God like he doesn't grab onto it
very easily all right let's dance
[Music]
let's get started
you never should have crossed us
[Music]
looks like we're not done yet
of course we're not done this dude's
done though
keep going
yes they already went this way
[Music]
okay I
had to have been going the wrong way
this time
thank you
look down there
it's down here
some kind of rare mineral I guess yeah
it's beautiful
all right that's the way I came
I bet you don't have to go back around
I don't know let's see
oh no I gotta go back around
[Music]
it's cool though
as long as no one else spawns we're good
um
need to pick me up
there we go
do this again this time let's go like we
supposed to
some clipping a little bit
flipping don't really bother me as much
as it bothers other people though
all right so I think that's just a
shortcut
come on
gotcha
we're clear
[Music]
okay I think I went that way
this is just taking me in circles I'm
missing something in here
that's right I can't get up there
I'm missing something
as long as I don't go into the into the
checkpoint I should be fine
I won't have to worry about anything
being resurrected or anything like that
oh my God
[Music]
look it's just like
gotta go down though
the little bar thing it should be a
little bit more
realistic than that I don't know
[Music]
there we go
God
going up this
all right let's see what this takes
how do you sense and Echo I've given you
everything I have
protect you I'm sure that's worth a few
more credits
all right let's see here
dude oh my God
no I'm definitely not doing a speed run
this is coming from the opposite side
that he was supposed to go
can I even jump back up there yeah
that might be like some side quest maybe
I don't know perhaps
all right so there is two ways
let's go this way
sounds like whatever that is up right
there we go
I don't know why it took me
oh this thing
foreign
's unblockable
all right let's go buddy
regret what
I ain't regretting nothing
I really didn't like you yeah I was a
fan of you either
way up let's look around
find something Buddy oh let me go get my
job real quick guys
session cable
worker season for construction now
can you repair it
uh
Cable's a bit frayed
it's not in bad shape should be a quick
patch job hmm
ah
so I heard you felt the Empire on
kashyyk
yeah
hijacked a walker and broke open an
imperial prison camp single-handed
that one was beating
just the two of you
and some friends
what about you new guy
win this for the credits
credits never hurt
uh
I have a daughter
Connor
I don't get to see her as often as I'd
like but at least I can provide for her
must be hard
being away from her
is her mother she's gone
the Empire took her from us
sorry
taking a lot of people
more every day
[Music]
you ever used one of those I'll figure
it out
it was a scrapper on broca
you've been through a lot for someone so
young just trying to survive
aren't we all
right
so we got the grapple
essential cables holding
good I got a feeling you're gonna need
it
well I like yeah it does the backflip
look at this guys it's clean look at
this
look at the back flip right before the
end
okay he didn't do it that time hold up
we won't do it again
yeah look at that side flip man
I love it
that wasn't so hard
this gaps could score somebody slicing
two Imperial we got a a coffee too good
Syndicate trade I got on the wrong side
of our employers
okay
Bravo used to fly for the Republic
military
I just started working with Coop and Liz
Cantina on North Street Bounty Hunter
got the drop on me the twins threw him
down a mine shaft friends ever since
do I need this to
hold on we got us to the senator
is that right Beauty
[Music]
you know shout out to EA for sending
Jedi Survivor Man really appreciate that
see who's gonna get it regardless
according to plan it's nice to play it a
little early
try to get it out uh try to get the
review up for IOP
depending if I get another review
but he's locked in pretty tight you
trying knocking
I just bet the twins of the senator had
you in there stuffed Mountain hey I want
to cut it
if you die I get the Mantis right sorry
gabs not mine again
hmm so what's the plan
I got to sign our RMC
Senator as military until on his
personal terminal here
would give us fighting chance against
the empire problem is Captain secured
glass doors even the twins can pry those
Bad Boys open how are we getting in
your Fella's got the yacht down Jeff
pack then I'll work myself
with my lovely assistant
I'll grab a transport
back before you know it
twins get Cal across that Gap
what should I do you got a jet pack use
it copy that
I need a
what's going on
do I jump off
yellow
nope
all right they ain't about me jumping
off so we're not going to jump off again
oh okay
that's right my dudes
thanks twins
keep your eyes sharp Bravo says
I do think the opening to Fallen orders
better than the opening to this game
next time
are you holding up just appreciating the
view what am I looking for two beans
wrapped around the yacht gotta take a
lot of to work
[Music]
yeah
there we go hey Cal I tried to move
those speeds but yeah gabs gave me the
heads up
well we're moving them all right
first beams down gaps can you tell the
twins to pull down the yacht got it
hold on
medium rare yeah yeah all clear cow long
way to drop
I care I can live through that drop
for the record I loosened it up for you
that's fine
nice job cow hop on we'll bring you down
I saw yours
[Music]
ready to break open this Rhapsody
I love the raw power this dude has
the raw power to be able to hold
yourself up look his Feet's not even
touching the ship
you know never could be me never could
be me
a lovely assistant to show you how it's
done
I knew we had unfinished business give
us your terminal passcode impossible
they'll execute me
maybe I could change his mind
will give me access to your terminal I
can't
hmm
unlock it and you'll be rewarded I'll be
rewarded I will unlock the term
[Music]
thank you
if he moves we'll ask him oh my pleasure
all right BD
see what we got
[Music]
they're everywhere
no the Breakthrough we were hoping for
years of fighting
and we've got to slow them down
what did you expect you're lost the
Republic is dead it was killed by
politicians just like you
do you think I wanted UTA power to join
the empire
the compromises I made created a future
for my people I've been to utapo senator
this but Junior
at least they are alive
why fight when you can't win
surrender tastes bitter at first come
but sweetens with time
free me
and we'll cut a deer
kill him
don't free him no Senator there you go
we don't negotiate with terrorists
a day when your children see this
they'll know the Jedi never stopped
fighting for them
how disappointingly naive
hey
they're getting that ravenous look let's
wrap it up before we have another karita
incident on our hands yeah what about
him he's coming with us okay let's take
their food to go
[Music]
lucky you Senator you've got a date with
saw Guerrera so I'll go kill me oh I
don't know about that depends on whether
you Coop get what we need that's a skill
Senator next you gotta get this Intel
top side
I've changed my mind we should always
Target the Empire yeah
feels good to make a difference no I
think I don't know what engine this is
Jared Mack I think it's unreal I don't
know by comparison
has more credits
what took you so long why you've been
chasing Shadows
[Music]
oh oh
it's another one of these big dudes you
have been caught harboring a traitor
okay
go
Cassius
oh man
no no
don't try to fight him
well guys
no
look at the anger inside
come back
hell where you going
[Music]
oh smash
all right
we gotta get to the Mantis
I hear you Dawn the twins
one more later gotta keep moving
[Music]
they're hunting us buddy gotta stay one
step ahead
jump towards Mark while I'm performing
okay
now we gotta fight that dude
man you you a veteran you've been
through an entire game
[Music]
might be
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's right
we don't play that game
[Music]
stem canister that'll prove useful
all right so we got more of that
give me one second guys I'm looking at
something
foreign
[Music]
situation yeah it's pretty much like you
meditate there to get all your stuff
yeah you gotta go
YouTube
not thinking about it they can they can
they can fly so I don't know how
effective that is toward them
it seemed effective though
yeah you ain't doing nothing okay
thank you all that
oh okay maybe maybe you had to be there
a little bit
foreign
[Music]
I only want to believe what's in there
we're gonna find out the
hold on moving out
[Music]
foreign
how do I get in there
he's in here somewhere we'll find him be
ready
hold up Empire's Pizza temporarily
confused help me out
I found me
[Music]
questions
come on let's go
[Music]
thank you
oh no I gotta go in
[Music]
I'm done with this place
I want to fight a night sister man
one second guys
[Music]
foreign
good to see you all right
spoke too soon I'll take the Inquisitor
keep that other gunship off my back on
it
[Music]
come here
yo this is good man this is good
[Music]
thank you
pastors here we go guys we bout to get
it we bout to go straight in
assistant let's go
why are you running
cause I ain't afraid of you
are you scared of me
[Music]
oh I can't I can't Dodge the Reds
impressive
but you're hurting bad inside kestus I
can sense it
oh they guilt you're feeling for those
fools you led to their deaths
makes you so so predictable
[Music]
oh dear Jedi a Corazon delicacy
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
thank you
oh man
[Music]
that shall be good
who is it
come here
don't push me away
come on come on come on
don't be scared Justice
foreign
oh I'm so annoyed
that was a good little fight though
if I faithful my fail
[Music]
all right let's try this again
oh so it's like one of those things you
come straight in okay
[Music]
that ain't happening again boys
we ain't getting hit again like that
yeah
behind you
impressive
but you're hurting bad inside
we're doing this let's go let's go
are you scared you nice sister
[Music]
so fired
I need help
[Music]
thank you
foreign
just me and you nice to stop
right there take your shot
I'll take your limbs off
thank you
oh Brad
[__] back here
[Music]
foreign
really
I might just let him grab me
angry
always
don't press it
back damn it
oh
all right let's try this again
[Music]
you can't stop this let's play a game
all right
wow
I didn't get that helpful
stop getting hit by those red moves
[Music]
impressive deductible
be your next move
oh your friend's all dead
anymore
[Music]
death will make me a legend
God
[Music]
come on man
I'm not playing games you're the one
playing games
oh he grabbed me
uh before he did that
[Music]
oh my God nice sister
thank you
I know I've been dreaming of this day
[Music]
he started to be very easily predictable
now
how about your head
learn a new trick
nah he's always been able to do this
I don't think so
desperate together
[Music]
whoa okay
my turn
oh my God the grass
I'm so angry
[Music]
friends all dead catches
your court will be a member
man the nice sister really messing me up
I wonder if you'll come down here with
me you know you can't escape
pretty sure I just did
pretty easily mad
[Music]
I'm here
I don't like the Dodge I feel like the
dog
I feel like I can't get back in the in
the yeah the fight quick enough
man I hate that
[Music]
enough ready
[Applause]
stupid move
desires
oh I like to play with my food
[Music]
sure you can handle those
questions
thank you
foreign
[Music]
night
before you betrayed our order
oh that was a good fight
the name was Asana tide
[Music]
it's time to set you free oh
yeah
okay
[Music]
we'll go single
this big dual
[Music]
Focus
ready to go
Bravo are you there
get back to the Mantis if the others
made it out we'll meet us at the hangar
this is a pretty decent first level
though
there we go
fish
I'll take him down
I'm not sure
I love how I'm fighting this dude and
acting like the others don't exist
oh
my God
I always enjoyed the climbing and like
the platforming in this game
[Music]
I don't know I think I got a switch
thank you
fingers close
okay let's see here
what's going on next
to our life thanks to this crazy son of
a gundark
you're hurt
I'll manage
what happened to The Inquisitor
dad
gaps
twins I should have they know what they
signed up for we need to get tub side
and transmit that endota Sol Guerrera
that's how we all know the Fallen
you're right
yep
after this guys I'm gonna call it a
stream I appreciate everyone for coming
through
[Music]
for Bravo
got overwatched
I'll draw the fire
you hit them when they aren't looking
let's get some Payback
see you in the next Grandpa
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna call a stream here guys I
gotta take a shower get ready got some
stuff I got to get taken care of expect
a review now I ain't gonna sit here and
lie to you guys okay I don't know when
the review is gonna come out when we
roll with you I'm a really try to have
this review out before
before IOP Sunday whoa daring IOP so
Premiere after ILP but I don't know that
means I have to play tonight
tomorrow Saturday
and at like middle of Saturday starting
the review and hopefully finish it by
Sunday morning I don't know yet though
but I appreciate it for coming through
you know let's see who uh who we can
raid real quick
[Music]
I gotta use the best
I'll be right back
there we go I feel better
all right let's see who we can send this
to
[Music]
uh I guess I'll send you guys over to
kids smooth
you guys have a good stream guys I
appreciate it for you all coming through
here
uh you know definitely go over there and
try to
try to tell kids who he needs he needs
to be reasonable on Twitter man he's
saying some off the wall stuff go over
there be reasonable with them man tell
him he needs to be on his best behavior
after his